and this is actually a question from an
HSC exam and it's yeah it's a it's a
sneaky one right so what do we do with
this it says find the shaded area again
and you get given the equation of this
curve y equals it's the natural log and
then you get given a couple of batteries
one two three so how do we deal with
this well from the outset the first
thing that you might want to do is say
oh this isn't what's so complicated okay
this is an area under a curve I know how
to deal with those so I'm going to
integrate they even give me the
boundaries how kind of them I'm going to
go from one to three and what's the
thing I'm integrating it's log X with
respect to X now at this point if you
are a clever advanced student you start
scratching your head because this is not
a function that you are supposed to know
how to integrate now you can actually
integrate it there are ways you know we
generally reserved those ways for
extension to students but I'll tell you
what most students in the exam do
instead of doing this correctly don't
write this down please they say oh log X
calculus I know what to do with log X
it's 1 over X and then they go from 1 to
3 and they're like wow what was so hard
about this question this is no big deal
ok now the problem here is the integral
of log X is not 1 over X the derivative
of log X is 1 over X so a classic error
that we often make I've made it many
times in the past is we've
differentiated instead of integrating
turns out the integral of log X is
rather more involved in challenging
which is why like I said you kind of
need some extension to techniques to
deal with it ok not impossible but I'd
rather not do it this way ok
so what's an alternative way to solve
this problem using the knowledge that
we've developed today well have a think
in the first half of the lesson we were
looking at areas bounded by the x-axis I
just went and spent a lot of effort
helping you develop an understanding of
areas bound it to a different axis the
y-axis how can that knowledge help me
here have a think look at the graph
closely and if you haven't already by
the way let me just buy you a bit of
time too
draw this thing for yourself because you
absolutely do need a bit of a drawing
it's not a parabola you're exactly right
so I'm not going to I'm not going to use
exactly the same technique that I used
before but I am gonna use something
related to that have a think ever think
we're going to combine sort of the the
two pieces of um the two methods we
looked at last time
okay Yvonne's Avon's on the right track
right let's let's have a think about
this okay what have we just determined
the area under the curve is not easy to
work out directly the area bounded to
the x-axis so how can I say for example
have an area about into the y-axis that
might help me well let's have a look
over here right if I worked out let's
put in there we go I put in an extra
line in here and if you want to on your
diagram and encourage you to do
something similar if I put in an extra
line over here and then say wait a
second I can work out I'll just stay on
stay on red I can work out this area
over here because it's bounded to the
y-axis
see that it's bounded between my y
equals log X and it goes all the way
over to the left to the y-axis here okay
this area which I've enclosed in red
this I can work out using the method
above I just need to be able to do those
three things number one change it so
that it's with respect to Y not X change
it so it doesn't look like Y in terms of
X but X in terms and Y and then get the
right boundaries right I'm not bout
integrating from one to three anymore
those expound erease I need some Y
boundaries to go with that so let's have
a go at doing this okay I'm gonna say
the area equals now again I'm going to
start from right to left even though
that seems a bit backwards but it's the
easiest way to go about this the first
thing is instead of writing an integral
with respect to X I'm gonna write an
integral with respect to Y okay no big
dramatic change so that parts done tick
now I focus on the next part right
that's this log X right this is in terms
X how do I get it in terms of Y well if
I have y equals log X what would I do to
change the subject
remember this is log base
e of X right so as of on put in the
comments I can convert this into an
exponential right now Y is the subject
but I can make X the subject if I
rephrase this in terms of Exponential's
powers and all that kind of thing
instead of as a log so what I can do is
I can say rearranging this the way I
think about it is this base becomes the
base of the new equation which is e and
then the XS and the Y's they kind of
switch around right so this Y is the
power and X is the new subject so this
guy here
I now have remade the equation so that X
is the subject and not Y so instead of
writing log X I'm going to write e to
the power of Y and this is making me
smile because I'm like I love
integrating e to the Y you don't have to
do very much to it's really simple right
so step 1 DX turns into dy step to that
log X I get it in terms of Y so it's now
e to power of Y the last step is let me
get these areas either way it's a bit
messy I need to look at these boundaries
right these guys whoops from color these
guys over here 1 & 3 are no longer
relevant to me ie to know what are the Y
boundaries here okay now the lower
boundary is easier right where does this
Y area start from at the bottom have a
look you guys can't tell me the value
right here what is this value it's 0
very good and sacha you've already gone
to the next step so I want the upper
boundary which is up here it's a Y value
but Y is equal to log X remember so I
just need the x value over here that
gives me that Y value and I know what
that x-value is it's 3 so if x equals 3
then Y will equal natural log of 3 ok so
that's my lower boundary and that's my
upper boundary so now when I come over
to here I'm integrating from naught to
log 3 so remember this thing here it
gives us the red area in fact I might
even say that this is the red area it's
not the actual shaded area we'll come to
that in my combine and conclude step
okay let's go ahead we've done enough
work let's work out what this thing is
integral of e dy is just going to be
thankfully e to the Y from nought to log
three and this is one of those examples
where it's going to pay to make sure
that you don't just say when you get
zero you just then you when you get
substitute zero you don't just get zero
this is even the power zero right so
you're not just going to get zero we get
e to the power of log three take away e
to the power zero okay now if you have a
look at this e to the log three business
maybe you're like my brain is confused
I'm you can do a couple of things here
number one your calculator will help you
it will just evaluate this for you if
you want but if you think back to your
log laws one of the log laws which is
not very well known it's not commonly
used is e to the power of log x equals x
it's a it's not common but you can prove
this quite easy to yourself by
rearranging this exponential equation
into a log equation right what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna take logs of both sides
which gives me this and then I notice
that this power up here I can move in
that's a terrible color sorry this power
here I can move it out of the front
using my log laws so log X outside the
front of log a equals log X so note
sorry did I do that right yeah I did do
that right okay so you can see that
these two things are going to be equal
so e to the power of log three and read
the sounder work it's in the way of my
working there we go shake you down a
size e to the power of log three is
going to just be three and then e to the
power zero as a lot of people said is
just going to be one so this guy is 2
which is kind of by the way a bit
mysterious right this weird looking like
this is the red area that we were just
working out right this weird bizarre
shape which is like got this funny curve
cut out of it it ends up being such a
simple number it's just two okay now
that's the red area to work out the
shaded area let's do it over here I'm
gonna move this guy out of the way the
shaded area is going to be that
rectangle take away the red area the one
we just worked out in fact I'm going to
write that it's the rectangle and I'm
going to subtract the red area so to
work out a rectangle we need length
times breath you can see the breadth is
pretty straightforward it's just three
right so I'll write that three what's
the height or the the length of this
well it's from naught to log three so
it's log three
there's the rectangle done right there
and then the red area we just worked out
was two so it's three log three take
away two and I would conclude by saying
the area with units so it's three log
three take away two units squared so
this whoopsie-daisy this is a tough
question right there was a lot to it you
had to think carefully about how you
would approach it and the trap for young
players is to just say oh it's log X and
I can integrate that when you're
actually differentiating so it's uh it's
it's almost designed to try and see if
you really know what you're talking
about but that's why these techniques
integrating with respect to Y and
getting other areas are so handy because
they can help you work out a wide
variety of questions